what advice you have for someone just
going you have to live humbly to get
what you want
the biggest problem for people going for
it is while they're building their
fitness brand they're not willing to
live with four roommates or work at
checkers got it
you can't have both cuz if you're gonna
go for it and you don't have the money
coming in right away you have to live
people think that they get to stay
living the same lifestyle they have when
they have another job you don't when you
go for it you got to take a step back in
your day-to-day for your future people
don't have the humility to work at
Burger King while they're getting there
[Music]
the thing is extremely interesting to me
especially the last two meetings I've
had with like it's gonna happen how are
you so nice to meet you of this year
[ __ ] you you mutt you continue to mark
it well okay you take the you take the
clip of Hoda and you've run it on
Facebook 242 six year olds in perpetuity
let me tell you something
I believe the communication of something
is equally as important as the quality
of something alright the best product in
the world not communicated well doesn't
sell the shittiest product in the world
communicated perfectly by me will not
work either
so I just think that you can't get to
your ambitions without being a perfect
executor in 2019 comms hold on the Today
Show Instagram swipe ups all of it all
of its great you know Sam yes
[Music]
I was just thinking picture my for five
minutes with you we figured out the most
subtle thing which was just the nuances
of my face even though I'm saying the
same stuff has made people like me more
because when I'm talking to every money
it's a faceless human and it comes off
more aggressive because there's no human
in front of me but when I'm talking
one-on-one
there's a subtle isn't interesting end
me and d-roc we're talking about this
for like ten minutes anyway nonetheless
all right the bag it out we're good try
make videos for them did the way Sam
design it because my videos will sell
better than little the whatnot
Thank You economy did better than crush
it because the difference was in the
little offers of twenty-five there was a
little video should I make it real quick
yeah okay cool
ready so for the thirty-five sneaker
barter deal I'm doing a five minute
Instagram lives
[Music]
can I tell you something that I would
love to challenge you to sleep on
because it's a very touchy issue that I
think you could help so many people I
know you know the macro the fact that
you navigated to the level you navigated
as a minority female you can help so
many 23 year-olds understand the context
difference of what you went through
versus what's happening now and not in
the I had it harder than you but you did
yeah and if you could if you can make it
not feel like I had it harder than you
and you can make it here is your
opportunity that I am envious of because
boy I wish I you know and by the way
right now where race relations are in
America is an alt is enough is it a high
isn't a high right so what that makes a
twenty-one-year-old field is it's harder
than ever yet I have a funny feeling you
know it is not harder than ever I know I
go there as a 42 year old white dude so
you know scary that is I go on Breakfast
Club and like it's easier than ever and
I'm like [ __ ] Jesus I'm gonna get
destroyed I'm a [ __ ] 42 year old
white dude I'm the method but for you to
say it you have so much more air cover
than I do and you would help them so
much because they would believe you more
than they believe me they would say easy
for you why dude [ __ ] you but they can't
do that to you and you could help them
think about what do you have to do to be
successful I think people like us don't
understand house I think it in history
people look back at what I figured out
as a really important moment which is it
is remarkable that I don't spend any
time being Gary Vee I figured out my
model which was following me you're not
gonna be able to do that if you take 15
to 20 minutes and whether we help with
that infrastructure you get an intern
million different things but if let me
tell you how easy it could be if you
text I'm gonna just use them Sal and be
like this week I want to talk about
cryptocurrency
if Sal shows up downstairs at the bar of
your building or at the Starbucks and
that 15 minutes is Sal asking you for
questions and you answer them and then
that is a LinkedIn post the next day in
first person right Sal writing it that
is that is what I've done I've run a 900
person company I'm not I don't time to
do like what I'm doing is I'm filming
this right now this meta moment might be
how a busy executive said I want it how
a busy executive needs just 15 minutes
to be in the content game this right
here is how I figured it out right
originally it was the askgaryvee show
where I did have to sit down for an hour
and interview Hanna and her six-year you
know at vaynermedia right now I've gone
much further down to daily be where I'm
just being filmed because I don't even
have that [ __ ] hour to do that
YouTube show then I did that for three
years and all of a sudden like that
confidence getting stale and weirdly in
the last month I'm back to doing a
little bit of a scary week I'm fighting
for that hour so but the key is how do
you not disrupt yourself but you need to
have something that's a pillar
[Music]
so I'm not like literally I know what I
want to do in my life I'm making a
filmmaker I'm a storyteller and that's
literally they can relate so yes right
here I used to work for when I arrived
to live in New York it's mighty one of
my first jobs just let's put Casey yes I
just worked for case it is too light and
and now that I found this opportunity
here
I'm almost two years here so I
understand everything what can I help
put I want I want anyone advice I want
advise in there because I mean I so much
you definitely go in the right direction
let me explain why my ability my ability
to get you a job with the biggest
directors in the world is very high and
the longer you stay and do great work
the more leverage you have with me so if
you want to leave right now I probably
will introduce you to some people and by
the way I would if you literally said
today's my last day I want to I know
you're not and I want to go to Hollywood
I would literally introduce you to five
people and if you go crush Mayo and work
for another year and in a year from now
you do that I'm gonna try harder you're
welcome to regular meeting and of course
always will be in touch yeah I got the
score how you doing you excited yeah of
course I mean I'm just quitting with no
like do you have some savings you'll be
okay great so you'll be okay great yeah
got it all mapped out like a budgeting
down just like I know you take six
months to invest it good for you
you're preachin brother listen I have
tons of relationships there doing a lot
of interesting stuff in that space yeah
just you know a lot of people yes me in
this meeting and then don't take me up
on it and then I see them three years
later and they're like yeah why didn't I
take you up on him I think there's a
level of a mix between cynicism or pride
or a million different reasons why
somebody would not take me up on it yeah
thank you I'm sure correct but I'm
desperate for you to understand how much
I appreciate the value you've brought
here and how much I want to return that
and so I'm here brother thank you so so
much I can't wait to see you again yes
sir
I'm glad you asked can you speak to how
you invest in vaynermedia employees that
are moving on to a new job yeah yeah
it's a good point yeah I mean look and
honestly if you're gonna decide to
narrate it this way like even use your
voice right now in here because I want
all of you to always know how this all
gets a post edited which is I'm out of
the equation yeah man look I'm playing
for life here when you play for
admiration and legacy you don't protrude
when an employee's leaving for whatever
reason you seen what I'm trying to do
I'm trying to put them on I want people
to say to their grandkids that I left oh
that guy Gary be on TV or whatever the
[ __ ] TV is in a hundred years yeah let
me tell you story I've worked for scope
you work for his company yeah when I was
leaving it instead of being a dick like
most people he helped me do you know why
I ever got into that VR company it was
cuz Gary Vee did that that's nice that's
legacy that's admiration I I will never
understand how people run their
companies with their selfish interest in
mind my selfish interest in mine is to
be selfless which then leads to
admiration listen I've had a very
interesting epiphany with myself the
last hundred days I'm like oh [ __ ] it's
admiration it's really blocked in you
know legacy was a way of saying that but
admiration is the short-term thing that
I can see can we show these faces guys
this is what I look they just walk in
and they're just like they've got
requests my life's about requests you
know what I am I'm like a [ __ ] show
pony
they're like pony do this
do that okay what would you like me to
do sir okay got it
ready Facebook family big news I've
started a watch page called to Gary the
video experience and a ton of action is
going down there tons of content if you
love the Facebook world as much as I do
head right now link in here head right
now and follow me on the Gary Vee video
experience as some of you may know I
rebranded my podcast to the Gary Vee
audio experience 18 months ago and I
want to go on video on Facebook we can
do that in watch form on the Gary Vee
video experience a ton of great stuff
going down there go follow now thank you
sir hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is pod sessions
pretty much my favorite pillar type that
I've created in last year or two but I
don't get to do often cuz you know first
I like mixing up the the guests I have
the format if you're listening or
watching for the first time as three
guests and I and we just kind of shoot
the [ __ ] talked about different stuff
people that I have contexts for either
I'm watching very carefully from afar or
actually know all three here I actually
know pretty well too my guy
I've been looking forward to this how
are you great to see you again man how
you been great sit sit baby money
doesn't change you fame and money takes
the energy out of you takes the hunger
out of you when you're not hung when
you're hungry and nobody's feeding you
but then you get a big [ __ ] 18
murders and you eat them all so I'm
trying to I'm always suppressing the
good then everybody's chasing because it
keeps me hungry as [ __ ] let me give you
the most liberating thing that I could
ever tell an artist or somebody try to
make something happen if you're good
enough it's gonna happen I believe in
that the most all the people that are
now 53 and they thought they were good
enough they weren't it wasn't that they
picked the wrong manager it wasn't that
the gatekeepers stopped him
they weren't good enough especially now
my guy what gatekeeper keep putting [ __ ]
on Soundcloud and Spotify are you
kidding me [ __ ] 20 years ago kilee
had no shot
there were gatekeepers there's no
[ __ ] gatekeepers Instagram YouTube
Spotify and SoundCloud that's the
gatekeeper and guess what even if you
run rap caviar you're not the gatekeeper
you're a Minnie Minnie Minnie geeky purr
how does [ __ ] show up on rap caviar not
bad shits happened then they pick but
you got to get to that first step
love your fans unconditionally put out
music that's in your [ __ ] soul [ __ ]
will happen Gary Vee you tell all the
rappers the same advice cuz it's the
[ __ ] truth dick no [ __ ] I'm telling
them the same [ __ ] [ __ ] I know
you're thinking this is same show you
talk exactly it's the truth get used to
it you know listen I'll give you another
piece of advice something this is advice
I give everybody you [ __ ] with somebody
in sports she's cute they're funny DMB
like yo I [ __ ] with you cuz you never
know when they're like oh oh oh I love
kill majora it's like in front I'm gonna
put that on my blog give love
everybody try to act cool I want to
create a blog post where people can
download four or five different audio
clips that I just recorded and make them
their alarm when they wake up
I want to completely take over the phone
alarm game in the same way that like my
backdrop is on a ton of people's screens
I think I think my alarm is going to
dominate so hey let's figure out the
function of if you have an Android or a
iPhone how you take it could be a blog
post how to you know take the alarm like
in there the step by step of how to do
that we need to make that I got the
files on that camera right now and that
is what Calvin's probably texted the
team about right now - if he's washed
his hands in the bathroom because I told
him it's where I came up with it just
now and that's it I like that to come
out next week
what's that Sonic branding birthday my
guy man I really think it's gonna happen
for you
I like hit him up and I was like yo
there's somebody I really want you to
look at I really really feel it I also
think you're saying something like I
like the way that you're like you're
painting pictures of your reality and a
very for me it's like how how it comes
through my head do I feel actually I
nobody said this you you've heard me
talk about it do I feel like I'm there
do I not feel like I'm there and that's
basically how I judge do I feel like I'm
rolling with the two of you through
Atlanta or do I not do I think I'm
watching you roll through and when I
feel like I'm in there that's when it
gets my attention
that's actually the answer of why I [ __ ]
with you one thing if they happen in six
years instead of one is how it actually
happens in one wanting to happen in one
is why 99% of people lose I believe in
that the most
I was always this happy my whole life
because I was raised in an environment
and I had the DNA that just did not
allow judgment to be part of you very at
all that's it and that's why I'm trying
to get everybody else to eliminate
judgment that's why I want you and him
to never ever ever care about what
anybody else thinks because it is game
over game over game over I'm unbeatable
I'm a hundred percent unbeatable for the
rest of my life I am because even if I
lose by your standards I can't hear you
if I lose it all
the next thing that goes through my mind
is I can't wait to stick it to everybody
when I come back I'm gonna take all
those social media comments and when I
come back I'm gonna make a 10 hour video
I'll be like let me tell you what the
world said about me six years ago when I
lost it all
[Music]